In this problem, a town's mass burn
incinerator has a name plate capacity of
500 tons per day. A new program begins
to recycle newspaper, corrugated board,
glass, aluminum, and ferrris cans with
an overall efficiency of 50%. The waste
stream composition and heating values
are given in the table. On a particular
day, the measured loss to the
incinerator, otherwise known as the
daily heat input removed due to
recycling, is 500 million BTU per day.
What percentage of the incoming waste
stream is corrugated board?
So in this problem, we are given a few
things to start with, none of which has
to come from a reference manual.
We know the capacity of the incinerator
is 500 tons per day and that half of
this capacity is now being recycled for
a specific set of items in the table. We
also know the total heat loss to the
incinerator aka the total amount of
items being recycled expressed in BTU
per day.
Given this information, we are being
asked to find the percent of corrugated
board that is present in the waist
stream.
Since there are two unknowns in the
waist stream, we can't simply sum them
all and subtract from 100%.
But since one of those unknowns,
aluminum, has no BTU value, we can
calculate and sum each item and then
backsolve for what is missing from the
total.
So, let's mark down which items the
problem is stating are included in
recycling and calculate their BTU per
day. We've got newspaper.
Eventually, we're going to need to solve
for corrugated board.
There is ferris cans, aluminum, and
glass.
So, starting with newspaper, we can
calculate the BTU per day as follows.
The percentage of the waist stream times
its specific heating value times the
recycling efficiency time the capacity
time the unit conversion of pounds per
ton to get us to the proper units
for newspaper. This brings us to 360
million BTUs per day.
Skipping corrugated board for now, we
can move on to ferris cans.
I will write down the new value specific
to that specific line item, but
reference the constants in order to save
time.
So for ferris cans, it's 2.9% of the
waist stream and 300 BTUs per pound.
If we calculate this out with the other
values in the equation,
this gets us to 4,350,000
BTUs per day. For aluminum, we don't
need to calculate anything since the
heating value is zero.
And for glass, we have 5% of the waist
stream times 60 BTU per day times all of
the other values referenced above.
And this will get us to 1.5 million BTU
per day.
Summing these up, we can see that all
line items recycled minus corrugated
board comes to 365,850,000
BTU per day.
So now we are ready to solve for our
unknown percentage of corrugated board
present in the waist stream. Let's write
it out.
So, our unknown percent in the waist
stream times 7,000 BTUs per pound* 50%
recycling
time 500 tons per day time 2,000 lb per
ton.
And that's going to be equal to
500 millionUS
365,850,000.
otherwise calculated to 134,150,000
BTU per day.
[Music]
So simplifying the above equation we can
see that we have 3.5 billion BTU per day
* X equals 134,150,000
BTU per day. Solving for X, we can find
that corrugated board is equal to about
3.8% of the total waist stream, which
most closely resembles the second answer
on the list.
So this problem is pretty
straightforward if you can keep track of
all the large numbers that you have to
calculate and can envision the
calculation you need to get to BTU per
day.
Finally,
you need to recognize that you can wait
to calculate corrugated board at the end
after subtracting all of the other
values from the total loss value of 500
million originally provided. And that's
it.